House committee will question Facebook
CEO Mark Zuckerberg in Washington later
this morning
he testified for nearly five hours
yesterday at a joint Senate committee
hearing Zuckerberg was asked about
privacy protection Russian interference
in the last election and whether
Facebook should be regulated as a
content provider I agree that we're
responsible for the content but we don't
produce the content I think that when
people ask us if we're a media company
or a publisher my understanding of what
the heart of what they're really getting
at is do we feel a responsibility for
the content on our platform the answer
to that I think is clearly yes and but I
don't think that that's incompatible
with fundamentally yet at our core being
a technology company were the main thing
that we do is have engineers and build
products Zuckerberg said failing to
detect and stop Russian election
interference was one of his quote
greatest regrets and he apologized for
waiting more than two years to tell
millions of Facebook users their
information was sold to Cambridge
analytic on Mark Zuckerberg has a long
history of public apologies dating back
further than Facebook itself in 2003
Zuckerberg apologized in the Harvard
Crimson for any harm done
after his website Facemash ask users to
rate people's hotness
three years later Zuckerberg said
Facebook quote really messed this one up
following user complaints that the newly
launched newsfeed invaded their privacy
Zuckerberg apologized once again in 2007
for an uproar over the company's beacon
advertising system saying I know we can
do better
one month later he discussed that
controversy on 60 minutes
I guess this shows how difficult it is
for a company like yours to make money
through advertising and protect people's
real privacy and their sense of privacy
you know it might take some work for us
to get this exactly right this is
something that we think is going to be a
really good thing since then Zuckerberg
has apologized at least four more times
over Facebook privacy concerns